hi everyone my name is Tamra chambers
and this is Tamra Jessa and today I went
and saw Pacific Rim - if you hear
clanging in the background it's my
washing machine a machine that I enjoy a
lot more than any of the machines in
this film there are gonna be any
spoilers in this reaction video though
there's nothing to spoil monsters fight
robots that's your weapon you me now
watch another video no don't please stay
a few weeks ago I saw a comment that
said Tamra every movie rules chambers
because I like everything all right I
like the wrinkle in time guys sue me I
liked the last Jedi sue me I liked Tomb
Raider sue me I liked the Dark Tower
sue me don't please don't sue me but I
liked him and yeah I sure did like this
it was fun and original oh and it pretty
and Pacific Rim is a film that I never
saw until yesterday before seeing
Pacific Rim - because it looks like a
dad Phil and I say that a lot about
generic action films it's one of those
films that is a generic action film it's
not gonna look great CGI isn't gonna be
amazing it's not gonna have a great
script it's not gonna have incredibly
in-depth characters for the most part
it's like that that recent one that came
out the gods of Egypt or whatever that's
the dad film you know what I'm saying
Pacific Rim in my eyes looks like a dad
film and I've always thought that's what
it was but then people started saying
actually it's pretty damn good there's
like a killer monsters like Godzilla
level monsters there's all these giant
robots great actors the director is
amazing and my one of my very best
friend Sally she was in a terrorist
never seen episode and this is like her
favorite action film of all time of all
time so I was very excited I was raring
to go I wanted to see it and then I
didn't because hi my name is jammer
that's kind of my thing
but I watched it yesterday
right before going to see Pacific Rim to
which in hindsight was a mistake I think
that was too much Pacific Rim in just
one sitting like I said it was a blast
Pacific Rim one what's so disappointing
the side characters just they annoyed
the crap out of me so much like what are
you doing what what are you doing and
then like the lead characters who I love
we're not good and not like there was no
depth to them at all it's like they
weren't there at all like a Juris what
are you dare mo del Toro directed this
film huh what am I missing something
it's just like turn off your your
critical thinking and just watch it for
some cool-ass monsters and some cool-ass
robots it's like okay cool yeah I guess
I understand that nothing in the story
added up if at the beginning the lead
was like I was never like top in my
class like sport started school and then
like they showed like a scene later like
a shirtless and completely jacked and
I'm like you okay you were in a sports
start I think that was by choice my
friend
like it just that was a stupid thing to
critique but like I don't know I wasn't
on board with one I told then I went in
to with him a brother Taylor last night
I think I went in with that negativity
already you know like I just got done
like the movie was a half hour after we
finished the first one so I think I just
went in with that like oh my god I'm so
not into this when I could have gone in
and like tried to have fun with it
the audience was having a lot of fun
with it people were laughing at jokes
that really didn't work for me the
comedy wasn't there though they gave a
lot of attempts at comedy I lasted a
couple things but mostly it wasn't funny
to me the CGI definitely looked better
in this second one and a little bit
there was a little bit more connection
with characters and a little bit more I
don't know caring feeling at all
it was really another excuse just to
watch gyre it was fight giant monsters
which cool if that's your thing and
that's why you want to see this awesome
definitely see it still not connecting
at all
still bad writing was just a sad face
that I drew does that Clint Eastwood's
son yeah that was Clint Eastwood's son
in the film Clint Eastwood son not good
I will say John boyega saved anything
that you could save from this film he
was so personality filled and he took
the lines that weren't great and turned
it into something worse I don't think
that the other actors did that I don't
think that Clint Eastwood son did that I
should figure out what his actual name
is and not just refer to him as Clint
Eastwood son I know he's more than that
that's John boyega was delightful and
the comedy that I did laugh at came from
him I know this isn't like the Beyonce
all but forty five percent on Rotten
Tomatoes but ninety percent of people
liked this movie what what so in the
first film there's these giant monsters
and humans build Yeager's which are
giant robots to fight the giant monsters
cool very cool on board so far in the
first film they destroyed the rift in
the bottom of the Pacific Ocean where
the monsters are coming from outer space
dimension
it's obviously done but dad film so
you're like cool number two what will it
be and somehow the monsters coming back
and some of this big a KERS the giant
robots going rogue and it's like they're
the bad guys now what so that's where at
in the storyline you're all caught up
now I wrote about the jaegers going rove
like duh if you have giant robots and
you give them to humans bad guys are
going to take those giant robots that's
just science that's just science I never
ever call things in filth ever I'm never
the one who's like oh my god that's
gonna never I'm never the one who
guesses things I never guessed the
ending to anything and I absolutely
guessed who the villain is in this
videos is so easy like six people left
at the theater and didn't come then I
just wrote my brother just fell asleep
it just fell asleep it was just this
generic action film with
excellent elements like really cool like
when you just tell me what it is
giant robots fighting giant monsters
yeah I want to watch that I want to
watch that all day long but it just
isn't executed well and like it's it's
pretty and it's like it looks big and it
looks like it has a big budget in it
looks like the actors are good and but
it just it doesn't fit together well it
really didn't come together story wise
and so you really don't have anything if
you don't have a good story you don't
have anything you don't have a good
dialogue you don't have good characters
who feel for each other you don't have
anything and and they would really go
for those moments of trying to have a
sentimental moment and and it wouldn't
work
and some of the characters really didn't
work at all for me in the first movie
this guy I hated that guy he got a
little bit better than the second one
but I do not understand his character at
all I don't understand the choices he
makes he's like this weird professor
plum character who's like just very like
Shakespearean and over-the-top and just
very like I'm in your face and it's like
this isn't an ale Simon play like what
are you doing right now if this
overacting it so weird Charlie Day who I
really enjoy always sunny but like he
gets character really also didn't work
for me in the first one I will say in
the second he does have a more
interesting angle and a more interesting
parts place in the film what is going on
he does have a more interesting part and
place in the film but I don't think I
got really anything good from him that I
cared about or like was invested in
except for in one part that was just
like real weird
like the only part of the movie that
made me feel like something anything and
it was weird and I was like hmm that's
when I guessed the ending the monsters
were by far the only part for me that I
really enjoyed the design of them is
really cool I'm so glad that they're all
very different so some of them look like
a fish show or like a like a shark or
like a beetle and it's awesome I love
the design of the monsters and even if
you get up close
would you do a few times in the film it
still feels like oh they're kind of
scary like they look good the CGI looks
a lot better in this one all in all I
know I said people left which they did
and my brother fell asleep which he did
and I was not enjoying it which I was
not but the audience seemed to be really
enjoying it it was a younger crowd I
think so that make sense it may be it
just wasn't for me maybe I missed it
maybe I completely missed why you love
this film maybe I walked in way too
cynical and way too negative from
watching the first one which I didn't
love no I just don't think that this is
the type of film for me like I just
don't like I don't like dad feelings
sorry dad and they set up for a third
because we need that Wow we need a third
movie so bad it's so good for Halloween
if I go as a Jaeger will you go as a
kaiju I would recommend this movie if
you have had a couple beers you're
hanging out with some friends you want
to go see something mindless easy stupid
absolutely go see this film thank you so
much for watching everyone I will see
you all next week with hopefully a
wonderful movie
[Music]